I've just come from chairing seven hours
of cabinet meetings focused on finding a
route out of the current an pass one
that will deliver the brexit the British
people voted for and allow us to move on
and begin bringing our divided country
back together I know there are some who
are so fed up with delay and endless
arguments that they would like to leave
with no deal next week
I've always been clear that we could
make a success of No Deal
in the long term but leaving with a deal
is the best solution so we will need a
further extension of article 51 that is
as short as possible and which ends when
we pass a deal and we need to be clear
what such an extension is for to ensure
we leave in a timely and orderly way
this debate this division cannot drag on
much longer it is putting members of
parliament and everyone else under
immense pressure and it is doing damage
to our politics despite the best efforts
of MPs the process that the House of
Commons has tried to lead has not come
up with an answer so today I am taking
action to break the logjam I'm offering
to sit down with the leader of the
opposition and to try to agree a plan
that we would both stick to to ensure
that we leave the European Union and
that we do so with a deal any plan would
have to agree the current withdrawal
agreement it has already been negotiated
with the 27 other members and the EU has
repeatedly said that it cannot and will
not be reopened what we need to focus on
is our future relationship with the EU
the ideal outcome of this process would
be to agree an approach on a future
relationship that delivers on the result
of the referendum that both the leader
of the Opposition and I could put to the
house for approval and which I could
then take to next week's European
Council however if we cannot agree on a
single unified approach then we would
instead agree a number of options for
the future relationship that we could
put to the house in a series of votes
to determine which course to pursue
crucially the government stands ready to
abide by the decision of the house but
to make this process work the opposition
would need to agree to this - the
government would then bring forward the
withdrawal agreement bill we would want
to agree a timetable for this bill to
ensure it is passed before the 22nd of
May so that the United Kingdom need not
take part in European parliamentary
elections this is a difficult time for
everyone
passions are running high on all sides
of the argument but we can and must find
the compromises that will deliver what
the British people voted for this is a
decisive moment in the story of these
islands and it requires national unity
to deliver the national interest